ich habe bei fünf verschiedenen Fast
Food-Ketten das jeweils teuerste Produkt
bestellt um herauszufinden ob es sich
lohnt deshalb lass uns nicht lange rum
reden sondern ab ins Auto zum ersten
Spot unser erster Spot heißt Starbucks
schauen wir uns mal auf der Karte um was
es gibt in den trockenen coffee
Frappuccino bitte inventi
Ciabatta ist vegan oder wie ach nice
cool und Bacon noch bitte was man auch
schon direkt mal sagen muss fürs Video
jetzt gerade ne hier gibt's nichts was
preislich durch die Decke springt aber
mega interessant ja ich dachte gerade es
ist das jetzt blöd für das Video oder
ist das gut ist es schlecht es gab
glaube ich fünf verschiedene Drinks die
in der Wand hier also der größten
Ausführung 7,90 € gekostet haben was
wirklich unfassbar viel ist ein Getränk
ich habe mich für den trocknet TV
entschieden aber überhaupt keine Ahnung
was mich da jetzt geschmacklich erwartet
das hier ist das Nord beef Ciabatta also
quasi ein veganes mit Soja
Geschnetzeltem noch mal schön
aufgetoastet ist richtig schön heiß und
dazu
ein Bacon cheeseburg beides jeweils 4,90
€ finde ich für etwas was warm gemacht
wird schon ein bisschen besser am Ende
des Tages wird man nicht den besten Deal
seines Lebens machen aber ich probiere
erstmal den
Kaffee Kino
[Musik]
sind wahrscheinlich diese Brösel hier
oben die an so eine Eiswaffel erinnern
sollen schmeckt wirklich wie so ein
geiler Kaffee
Milkshake beefabatta ich probiere das
Ding mal ich glaube ich laufe Gefahr mir
den Mund zu verbrennen so wie das gerade
gedampft habe
[Musik]
kennt das mittlerweile von mir außen
crispy ne ganz ehrlich
dieses heiße Ciabatta Drink dazu der
späteren Sachen abschneiden McDonald's
Burger King alle haben Premium Produkte
und wir kennen die Klassiker das finden
wir heute heraus ob sich das Ganze lohnt
freue mich auf jeden Fall über eine
schöne Ausrede den ganzen Tag Fast Food
zu essen das Ding hier es schmeckt für
mich genauso wie es schmecken soll süß
wie Milchshake bisschen eisig und dazu
dann halt noch die Kaffee Note 9 von 10
für mich ich finde es übelst lecker
auf jeden Fall guckt euch das mal an
die Konsistenz ist nicht so gut der
Bacon ist nicht schlecht danach es
schmeckt aber lecker ist eine sechs von
zehn die man sich immer mal wiedergeben
kann von Starbucks die deutsche Fast
Food Landschaft hat noch einiges zu
bieten deshalb gucken wir uns den
nächsten Spot an Starbucks ist wirklich
vollkommen in Ordnung finde ich zweiter
Sport Burger King gehen wir rein und
schauen was das teuerste auf der Burger
jetzt gucken wir mal wie das gute Stück
hier aussieht frisch zubereitet worden
boah das ist wirklich ein Apparat wir
haben gerade nachgefragt double
Steakhouse dachte ich sei der teuerste
gibt es gar nicht mehr aber der hat das
Band vom double Steakhouse dieses
geteilte Band mit diesem Maismehl hier
oben drauf einfach notiert Chips drauf
Tomate Eisbergsalat unten drunter noch
mal wahrscheinlich eine cheese Soße
probieren wir das Ganze
Burger King sind schon einfach strong
muss man sagen boah ich habe eine schöne
Schärfe ich habe den Crunch von den
Nachos wir haben sogar Jalapenos oben in
der drin so sieht der nicht besonders
gut aus ich glaube da ist schon besser
unterwegs wir haben ja dann bei den
special-burgern diese Hochglanz da
werden wir später bestimmt auch noch was
sehen 8,99 €
habe ich mir lieber
Cheeseburger auf 98 kriegst du doch
einen stabilen Burger also
stabilenburger Bude
ja Eric macht heute die Bewertung hier
am Ende sammelt sich jetzt auch die Soße
merkt man ich würde ganz ehrlich
bewerten 7,0 schön also einfach sieben
sagen können
7,00
€ teuer
also der Grand Barbecue cheese
McDonald's Supreme colabo von Supreme
New York die die Skateboards auch machen
echt gut aus in der Werbung
1:1 genau gleich
okay also das geht besser ne also so ein
bisschen auseinandergefallen ein
bisschen Salat bisschen cheese bisschen
bisschen sind auch so nebeneinander
welches relativ dick ausfällt für Meckes
Verhältnisse käsig ist das ganze auf
jeden Fall
Fleisch komplett durchgebraten keinerlei
Spur von dem Medium Patti da zu sehen
hätte ich jetzt gedacht vielleicht was
auch nicht so mega schön dass der Käse
so schwitzt und es schmeckt aber besser
aussieht es schmeckt mir schon echt gut
muss ich sagen also ja wir haben gerade
13 Uhr wir waren schon bei drei fast
fünf Sports was mache ich mit meinem
Leben zum Glück habe ich die Jungs damit
die Frage die uns stellen müssen ist ja
lohnt es sich das teuerste zu bestellen
bei Burger King haben wir gesagt nein es
lohnt sich nicht ich glaube auch hier
lohnt es sich nicht in dem Moment das
teuer der ist schon anders als alle
anderen ich finde wenn man einen
besonderen Burger bei Max essen will
dann sollte man den Essen
Kinderparadies aber das schmeckt schon
deutlich besser als so ein Big Mac ja
hier ist der schon hier
ist richtig ist der Burger den du bei
Max bestellst wenn du nicht bei Meckes
essen willst
du musst es mitgehen weil du hast
trotzdem auf eine Art
von mir tatsächlich achteinhalb in
diesem Fall gewinnt für mich
ausnahmsweise Mecces weil sonst bin ich
großer Burger King Krieger aber heute
holt macces die Krone zumindest unter
den beiden schauen wir mal was sonst
noch so geht nächster Spot Innenstadt
five guys gehen wir rein und gucken was
es so gibt also wir haben eine Order mit
einem all the way Bacon Cheeseburger all
the way das ist quasi eine
Zusammenstellung von Toppings die man da
drauf bestellen kann kurze viele von
euch werden das kennen es gibt seit ein
paar Jahren in Deutschland ist eine
amerikanische Fast Food Kette ich habe
mich schon sehr gefreut als nach
Deutschland gekommen ist doppelt
eingepackt weil er so fett ist da muss
man sagen diese Burger hier bei Five
Guys die sehen schon sehr offiziell aus
die sind halt wirklich der Inbegriff von
so einem American Burger die smashion ja
hier die Patties frisch dann hat man
einfach diese Toppings Gewürzgurken oben
drauf ein bisschen Mayonnaise ich glaube
Ketchup ist auch mit drauf gegrillte
zwiebelnummer
Leute klassischer Tag rein in die Masse
es ist fast tot so vom ganzen Konzept
von der Definition her aber es ist was
eigentlich das ist kein Premium Standard
Burger irgendwie von Peter pane oder
Hans im Glück ist einfach was Eigenes
dieser fettige amerikanische Traum
zwischen zwei Brot helfen
checkst du das was du gerade gesagt hast
das steht so als Zitate irgendwo five
guys hatten besonderen Platz in meinem
Herzen es ist leider wahr das ist auch
geschmacklich für mich Essen einen neuen
verstehe jeden der sagt dass das nicht
sein ist weil das zu mächtig zu Labor zu
kompakt ist aber ich liebe das halt ne
dazu und grape Soda
und ich bin nicht mehr in Deutschland
wir werden von Burger zu Burger immer
besser auch im Ranking was wird das
nächste bringen
dass wir noch zu dem nächsten gehen
Tag Freunde ich werde jetzt genussvoll
mit den Jungs diesen Burger hier
verdrücken dann machen es auf dem Weg zu
Subway und mein letztes Mal das teuerste
auf der Karte zu bestellen unser
nächster Stopp heißt doch nicht Subway
sondern Pizza hat wir wechseln das Genre
keine Burger mehr sondern eine saftige
große Pizza die ziemlich ziemlich teuer
ist da ist der Apparat
26,99 € einmal kurz reinschauen
27 € Maria also für das Geld muss das
Schmecken warte dass wir sowas teures da
bekommen überhaupt ich habe hier noch
nie eine Pizza für annähernd so viel
Geld gegessen
sehr sehr gespannt ob das Ding das hier
ist doch ein Apparat oder ein Stück hat
so viel Kalorien wie eine ganze normale
würde ich fast
auch mit so einem öligen Rand
hier normal sowas schwebte mir auch
heute für Franklin gemacht haben weil
die das wirklich zusammen die ist aber
auch schon so ausgehärtet die cheesy ein
bisschen okay Freunde probieren wir die
27 Euro Pizza
[Musik]
kann man nichts sagen Alter dann Gehirn
sagt Gib mir mehr davon
wie ist teigig fettig oder sowas
fertiges habe ich lange nicht gegessen
eine knapp 30 € Pizza ist komplett crazy
wenn man drüber nachdenkt aber glaube du
kannst diese Pizza nicht alleine essen
du kannst sie auch schwer zu zweit essen
das ist eigentlich eine Pizza für drei
Leute ich habe gerade mal nachgeschaut
eine vergleichbare Pizza hat laut Pizza
hat Website
4400 Kalorien denn überhaupt sollte man
sich die Pizza zu vier Teilen das ordnet
den Preis wieder so ein bisschen ein
aber ich finde es irgendwie trotzdem zu
teuer Alter 27 € absolut pervers auf
jeden Fall lecker übelst teuer welche
Note nur den Geschmack bewerten müsste
gebe ich dir aber schon so eine Art ja
safe die ist hammer lecker ne das ist
krank ja ist lecker aber die ist halt
wirklich einfach schlecht für dich die
ist ungesund ungesund war unser gesamtes
Video heute ein Tag nur das teuerste bei
Fast Food Ketten bestellen also es waren
einige Überraschungen dabei einige
Enttäuschungen einige positive
Überraschung wollt ihr das ganze mal in
der Budget Version also dass wir quasi
überall nur die aller günstigsten Sachen
bestellen schreibt in die Kommentare wir
sehen uns beim nächsten Video bis dahin
ciao ciao
und bist du gespannt den schießen nach
Show lover